Kim Kardashian and Kanye West have
officially settled their divorce yep
this settlement comes nearly two years
after the reality star filed for divorce
from the rapper ending their six-year
marriage what are all the possibilities
that can happen what's my life going to
look like I really want to be active for
my kids
et's learned Kim and Kanye will share
joint custody of their four kids with
quote equal access but Kim will still
have the children the majority of the
time they share nine-year-old North
six-year-old Saint four-year-old Chicago
and three-year-old song they do have
you know a family that I have to just be
positive and get it together for the
settlement confirmed Kanye will Fork
over two hundred thousand dollars per
month in child support he's also
responsible for an equal share of the
kids school and Security expenses so
definitely have our our rules
um is the best that you can do according
to their prenup agreement both Kim and
Kanye waived any spousal support and
division of assets but any dispute
regarding their kids will be resolved
through mediation it's not an easy
transition during the contentious
divorce and custody battle Kanye made
many claims including accusing Kim of
not allowing him to see his kids in one
instance he alleges he didn't get an
invite to his daughter Chicago's fourth
birthday party we have different views
sometimes we have different things at
the time A source told E.T that Kim was
quote overwhelmed and upset by Kanye's
Outburst adding Kim's main priority has
has always been their children her goal
has always been to have a healthy
co-parenting relationship with Kanye
where both of them are involved it was
really tough for me nearly a year later
seems the two are on the same page and
leaving things on good terms